en tout cas on le voit la cire il
devient de plus en plus un terrain de
guerre internationale frédéric il faut
rappeler d'abord que c'est un conflit
qui dure depuis quatre ans et qui
dégénère aussi depuis quatre ans oui
vraiment dans les proportions très
inquiétantes en fait céline depuis 2011
cette guerre civile a déjà créé
malheureusement plus de 250 mille morts
et provoqué le déplacement de quatre
millions de réfugiés c'est pas peu dire
ces réfugiés dont on parle beaucoup donc
extrêmement complexe un temps la
situation en syrie qui se bat contre qui
quelles sont les forces en présence
alors on va essayer de simplifier en
disant qu'il ya vraiment quatre grands
groupes alors évidemment le premier
c'est l'homme fort de damas et bachar al
assad c'est le président qui règne sans
partage avec peu d'égard pour sa
population depuis 15 ans maintenant donc
il est principalement situé ici on voit
sa zone d'influencé contre lui il y a
les forces rebelles qui sont au nord est
puis au sud ce qui sont ces forces
rebelles en fait c'est un amalgame un
peu étrange
bon il ya l'armée syrienne libre mais il
ya également des groupes islamistes dont
le front a nostra qui lui est affilié à
al qaïda
vous voyez cette alliance un peu un peu
étrange ensuite il y a les forces kurdes
qui sont principalement dans le nord et
qui essaie d'étendre ce qu'ils appellent
leur entité territoriale du kurdistan
et puis enfin bien sûr l'état islamique
qui vous voyez a assis son fief
particulièrement à jaca mais qui est
aussi très présent du côté iranien
évidemment tous ces gens qui se battront
des appuis de l'extérieur là deux pays
dans la région
oui il faut savoir que en fait c'est
vraiment deux groupes là qui s'oppose de
façon préférentielle et sunnites et les
chiites alors qu'ils qui soutient qu'il
a dedans en fait bachar al assad lui il
a le soutien justement des chiffres
parce qu'il est proche c'est un alaouite
donc proche de ce groupe des chiites
donc forcément il est soutenu par l'iran
et notamment aussi par le hezbollah qui
est notamment basée au liban
ensuite les rebelles celle inverse ils
sont soutenus forcément par les sunnites
dont qui s'opposent au shit et soutenu
également par la turquie la jordanie de
l'arabie saoudite qui fournit énormément
d'argent mais également de l'armement
les cures saoudite grands ennemis de
l'iran là évidemment on le voit là c'est
en train vraiment de se cristalliser les
kurdes peuvent compter sur leurs
confrères turcs et irakiens et l'état
islamique qui reçoit l'appui de pays
on va dire secret parce qu'on ne veut
pas le mentionner
il ya également plus de 30 mille
combattants qui viennent de l'étranger
qui prêtent main-forte évidemment à
l'état islamique et à ça tout ça
s'ajoute les puissances les grandes
puissances qui appuient l est qui ont
chacune leur intérêt dans cette région
évidemment on va commencer avec la
russie bien sûr de vladimir poutine
et là c'est une alliée vraiment
indéfectible la russie de bachar al
assad depuis le début en fait c'est
quasiment le seul allié russe dans la
région qui majoritairement influencé par
la présence américaine
en face les rebelles sont soutenus par
les américains et par la coalition dont
notamment fait partie le canada
alors il ya beaucoup de frictions
évidemment et des alliances un peu
contre nature au début c'était la russie
qui tirait contre les rebelles là
maintenant on les voit qui salit un peu
plus avec les états unis au grand
plaisir de la france d'ailleurs pour
combattre l'état islamique la turquie
est un allié des états unis mme ans pose
des questions en fait parce que en fait
ils continuent de combattre les kurdes
qui sont quand même des alliés dans la
bataille contre assad
et puis en même temps on se pose la
question la turquie et n'est-elle pas en
train d'aider notamment l'état islamique
en laissant passer des convois de
carburant qui viennent de l'état
islamique qui permettent de financer les
coffres du groupe armé bref assez
explosif comme région merci duo frédéric
après